listen it's it's it's a stiffest penalty
that that any team has ever taken or
given and we accept that we're gonna
move forward in a positive way
I'll let the Commissioner determine how
he handles the rest of it alright so the
manager is gone the general manager is
gone punishment imposed upon the Astros
it kind of reminds me the bounty scandal
from eight years ago in New Orleans but
Sean Payton stayed and is still there
the and Mickey Loomis stayed and is
still there but in Houston a total and
complete housecleaning and Peter here's
the thing that first resonated with me
when I saw this and I had heard about
the sign stealing scandal that caused
this to happen Alex Cora the Red Sox
manager is supposedly in line for
significant punishment as well in this
age of legalized gambling this kind of
thing cannot happen because not only are
you screwing over your competitors you
are affecting the integrity of the
wagers that are being made on a now
legal basis all the years it was illegal
nobody cares as I said yesterday at pft
it's like somebody going to the cops to
complain they tried to buy marijuana it
was actually oregano you're not gonna do
it and if you do they're not gonna care
when it's legalized and when it's
tainted that's when you have a problem
whether it's the creation of an agency
that will be responsible for overseeing
professional sports and ensuring
integrity like these Securities and
Exchange Commission does with buying and
selling stocks which is essentially
gambling or at some point they may
create laws that will make it easier to
prosecute people who are involved in
cheating in professional collegiate
sports that's the concern that every
league and team executive needs to have
in the aftermath of this baseball signed
stealing scandal the best thing the NFL
did for this to try to it basically shut
it off at the pass cut it off at the
pass is when they allowed the the
defense to have a player with the
speaker in his helmet so that he could
hear the defensive signals so the way
that the page
it's theoretically were able to match up
signals for what was run in the game
previously by a team so now that
theoretically can no longer happen the
next level I believe is working with
play with guys on the sidelines who
could have the smartwatches
and that way remember when ray farmer
the Browns was caught talking via
texting to guys in his own coaches box
during the game now I think it could go
even further imagine you've got one of
your practice squad guys on the
sidelines and he's got a smart watch and
somebody can be watching the game from
upstairs
texting instructions thoughts whatever
to somebody on the sidelines with a
smart watch that and I'm not saying that
happens but I'm saying that that to me
is next level that the NFL and not only
the NFL but other sports have to worry
about and I think the real concern here
at the heart is ensuring that the NFL is
doing everything in its power and every
sports league doing everything in their
power to make sure that the outcome of a
game the final score any objective
measurement that could be the basis of a
wager is something that is the product
of only the performance of the athletes
the skills and abilities of the coaches
and nothing more officiating errors I
think this is a greater responsibility
than ever to minimize if not eliminate
those and any type of cheating needs to
be dealt with harshly and severely and
you know the problem is when you expose
cheating you attract the attention of
lawmakers and prosecutors and I think
Rob Manfred the Commissioner of MLB
tried his best to walk this tightrope by
saying oh there's no evidence it
affected any games are you kidding me of
course it affects games if they know
what the pitches are going to be they
have a hell of an advantage over any
other batter that's up there trying to
guess and read the seams of a ball
that's moving 80 miles an hour so yes it
helps and they don't want to admit that
it helps because I think Peter the big
concern is when you acknowledge
that people are messing with the
integrity of the outcome of that wager
that's when you start having a real
problem with the government whether it's
Congress whether it's the district
attorney whatever the case may be these
sports leagues are gonna have problems
if they have issues like this in the
future and one of them is gonna be the
tipping point that blows it all up yeah
I think right now this is a clarion call
to every competitive venture especially
sports teams sports leagues and I will
not be surprised if there was a a memo
sent by either Roger Goodell or Troy
Vincent or Jeff Bosch two teams to all
32 teams that this is a reminder let's
make sure that our house is in order and
this never happens to us yeah and you
know beyond that and this is where they
need to be very proactive and we know
from history that the NFL sometimes is a
little reactive they wait for the bad
thing to happen and then they figure out
how to keep it from happening ever again
I don't think you can take that chance
in an age of gambling think of all the
ways once gambling is legal once there
is in stadium gaming and you know
there's wagers based upon whether or not
a play is going to be a run or a pass
and who on the sidelines knows what the
play is gonna be and is somebody
signaling to someone in the stands so
they can just sit there and get it right
eight out of ten times you don't want to
go ten out of ten then it becomes
obvious but I think those are things
they need to be thinking of all of the
temptations to affect the outcome of a
game to take advantage of inside
information you have to be very creative
in your brainstorming of all the things
that could go wrong and come up with
methods Peter that are aimed at keeping
those problems from ever happening not
waiting until they happen and say how do
we keep this from happening again keep
it from ever happening in the first
place
and I think the one other thing Mike
that you refer to that I think is
vitally vitally important is that these
leagues think ahead okay and not just
think well geez that was a really severe
sanction well okay well what's next
everything is the same we read all these
stories now about how you know the
Russians are getting ahead of us in
terms of protecting the sanctity of the
voting booth and and you know now we
have to worry about that and so in my
opinion these leagues need to think two
and three years ahead absolutely I
couldn't agree more instead of thinking
in the moment and dealing with the mess
once the mess is on the floor and you
have to get out of my
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports